- They like, you know,
you gon' be a top-20,
whatever, whatever.
So I had great workouts, great meetings.
People calling me all the way up
until the draft date.
So when I get there and
it's like, aight,
I'm still waiting, still waiting.
It's like, the way I was
waiting for that long,
it's like, aight. You know,
you gon' pay for that.
You gon' pay for that for sure.
♪♪♪
- [Announcer:] Heidegger kicks
it out to Sharife Cooper,
who has the shot
and he nails it!
Sharife Cooper for three, wins the game!
- [Eric Yeboah:] So first question is,
from AOT, McEachern, Jersey,
your path, you finally got now
to your first NBA media training camp.
What does it feel like?
- Oh, it's still surreal.
I don't think I've taken it in yet.
Like, I just feel like once you get,
you know, to this level,
it's like, you got so much
more that you want to do
and accomplish, it's
like, you can't really,
you know, take a step back
and be like, all right,
I made it.
- I think patience is the first word
that comes to mind for you.
Last season, you had to be
patient to finally start playing.
Now, what is it?
What does the word patience mean to you?
- Patience, sacrifice.
Those are two words I've
been, you know, raised up on.
So, I mentioned that I know
something, nothing that,
you know, kind of rattle me.
You know, it's hard when
you finally get to a point
and then stuff just randomly happen
that you had no clue of
or no control over.
So that's probably the hard
part, understanding that,
but, you know, now it's like a next step
and try to take control of your journey.
- We've always seen you
be real calm and cool.
I think it's only been a few times
I've actually seen you show that emotion.
What makes you so calm
out there and stay even-keeled?
- Yeah, I don't know how I level it out, honestly.
Cuz on the court, it's like, it's all a go.
It's like whatever, it's whatever.
But my face never kinda change,
but my attitude is like,
it's definitely, you know,
kill at all time.
- I think the only times we've seen you
with that emotion was
versus St. Patrick's a couple years ago.
If you remember, the scene was crazy,
the crowd was going really nuts.
And I saw that emotion out of
you. You turned to the crowd,
it was very, like, animated and whatnot.
You know, what was that game like?
- Yeah, just being back, you know,
where it kinda all started,
in Jersey, all my family from Jersey.
A lot of them still live there.
So being at where it's all
started from,
being that I was coming back,
playing against a team
that's in the middle of Jersey.
The crowd was crazy.
They talking trash.
I haven't been like that in a long time.
Like just, you know, emotion like that.
But it was like, they was so on the court,
like you could hear everything.
So when I'm hearing everything,
just mainly from this side of this crowd,
so you make a couple of shots,
it's like, what?
Like, why y'all not talking?
So that's all it was.
It was definitely a fun experience, though.
- Yeah. You've mentioned some of the,
some players that you really, like,
model your game after,
look up to.
And it seems like CP is like, a first.
You know, Chris Paul.
What is it you take from him
and what is y'all relationship like?
- What I take from him, just the way
he can balance passing and scoring.
I never felt like I was a
scoring or a pass first.
I felt like I could do a
mix of both at a high level.
So that's one person I really
see that, you know,
could mix both and still be effective.
So just watching him throughout the years,
the whole time I grew up.
That's somebody I kind of see myself similar to.
I'm not jumping over the rim,
not doing all that,
but you always is one of the
best players on the floor.
So that's somebody I look up to.
And we had a great relationship
ever since we played their team in eighth grade
and he was there and we lost,
and I actually had a good game,
but you know,
he kinda respected my game.
He seen me crying
and he [chuckling]—he's like,
"show me," he said,
"Show me somebody who like losing,
and I'll show you a loser."
That's something he says,
and that's what he told me after the game.
So we just had a good relationship
ever since then.
- What is your leadership style?
Like, if you can describe it?
- I want to win at all costs.
I feel like I have a good understanding
of people and my teammates.
I always had a great
relationship with everybody.
So I know how to talk to
certain people a certain way.
I know who can take yelling and who can't.
So everything I do is kind of
based off when it's,
whatever I say come from a good heart.
My team know that.
I don't really do too much yelling,
but, you know, when I say something,
it's mutual respect.
- Did you, I mean, even draft night,
I wanted to ask you about.
Like, what was that night like
in the sense of being so,
waiting so long?
We talked about patience earlier
and waiting to hear your name
and that relief that
came out your face.
But like, what was the first thing that popped
in your mind after you
finally heard your name
that's like, all right.
- It was hard, honestly.
Cuz you know, when I came out of college
in the projected lottery,
this, this and that,
all the way over to the combine,
they like, you gon' be a top-20,
whatever, whatever.
So I had great workouts, great meetings.
People, you know,
calling me all the way
up until the draft date.
So when I get there
and it's like, aight, I'm still waiting,
still waiting.
It's like, the way I was waiting
for that long it's like, aight,
you gon' pay for that.
You gon' pay for that for sure.
- Yeah. Did you, I mean,
I know that the chip on your shoulder,
I'm sure it's huge now.
We're coming into the season
and the goals that you have
set out for yourself.
What do you have set out to accomplish?
Let's just say rookie year, year one.
- I don't know.
There's so much up in the air.
I just want to, you know,
go in to practice the next day
and just, you know, dominate.
I feel I got a lot to show,
stuff that I haven't shown yet,
that I feel like I show all the time on,
outside of the camera.
So I'm just ready for practice, man.
That's it. I'm ready for the
next practice, training camp.
And then after that, the next practice.
So that's all my mind is set on.
The games,
I haven't even experienced the games,
so I don't know what it's like.
So I'm not really worried
about that right now.
- Yeah.
Did you feel like you showed a good arsenal
of your game in summer league?
Summer league was like, really exciting
to see how you running the offense,
you and Jalen [Johnson],
the way you guys kinda
handle things together,
the game-winning shot you had.
What do you think
you were able to show summer league this past—
- I feel like I showed it a little bit.
Nothing to what I think
I can show.
I get better off playing five-on-five
and stuff like that.
So that's kind of how I develop a rhythm.
I've been playing a lot of five-on-five
after the summer league,
so I feel like I'm in a
great rhythm right now.
I did all right.
I think I'd give myself a C, C-plus
for what I did.
- You have a very strong fanbase.
I don't know if you're aware of that [laughing],
but they'll do anything for you.
What is it like
just having that support system,
you know, fans that really
ride with you constantly?
And it's like, yo, if we,
if they see a top 10 of point guards,
if they see a list and
it's like, oh, where's Sharife?
It's quickly being asked,
where's Sharife at?
But they really ride for you.
What is that like?
- It's dope.
It's great to have a support staff outside,
you know, of your, of
your family and anything.
I see the same stuff you see.
I mean, they always got my back.
When somebody say
something that's not true
or whatever the case may be,
they always the first one to respond.
So, you know,
I'm super thankful for them, for sure.
- If somebody asks you right now,
which one you gotta claim,
is it Jersey or is it Atlanta?
- [Laughing]
- And why too?
- I have to go with both.
I feel like I'm from my roots,
you know, my heart, my blood
is in Jersey.
But you know, I grew up in Georgia,
so I always gon' have that, you know,
tie to both of them.
But definitely, I probably say Jersey.
I love Atlanta though, still.
I grew up here, you know, ATL.
That's what I got on my jersey.
- Yeah.
- So that's who we rockin' with.
♪♪♪
So that's who we rocking with.